[Music]
Laura thanks for joining spectator TV
you've written a brilliant piece for
spectator life about why chivalry is
dead do you think it can ever come back
from the grave yes I think it can look
I'll be honest I don't think it's
completely dead um I think I may have
said in the article it's actually
incinerated um and sometimes it can feel
like that but it's not completely dead
look my my teenage Sons I I told them
about what happened to me and they were
both astonished they said they still
offer their seats for ladies for the
elderly so you know some people are
still doing it let's dive into what
happened to you you had a horrible
experience on the tube it wasn't just
that this gentleman although I think
that's a rich description of him
probably too generous it's not just that
he wouldn't give up his seat he wouldn't
move his
bag I know it was so funny I actually
thought he was joking so it it might
seem a bit Petty to hook a whole article
onto one experience but what it was for
me was this nail in the coffin of
chivalry so picture the scene it's hot I
mean it's like a furnace it's the
underground I've been wearing heels all
day got a little bit of sciatica I'm
tired I'm tired and there were no spare
seats but this one gentleman um had a
suitcase in a bag on a seat next to him
so I got to him and I politely say
excuse me would you mind moving your
back so I can sit down and he he took a
he took a slug from his can of beer and
he looked at me and he said no I said
what really I thought it was a joke and
he said it's a priority seat for
luggage which it which it was but
nothing makes you feel like more of an
old bag than when a man won't move his
bag for you I just thought it was
incredible because I wasn't asking for
his seat I was asking for his suitcase
his seat and actually next to him was a
young lady uh nothing to do with him and
she she sprang out of her seat and she
said oh would you like my
seat but I've got to say by this stage I
didn't actually want to sit next to him
you know you acquire a kind of an
inbuilt radar over the years if if a man
gives off a funny sort of vibe if he
seems aggressive you don't want to put
yourself next to him you're going to the
other side of the carage the other side
of the carriage not sitting next to him
and his um his very tired suitcase but
this this young woman and I end up
looking at each other you know our eyes
kind of widening with shock and talking
about the fact that chivalry was dead um
and you know the week after another
incident happened which sort of cemented
it for me I was on an even more crowded
Carriage so crowded that I couldn't go
over a March over to help this woman but
she was wearing a mask which of course
no one's doing anymore and she had not
hair on her head and I thought it looks
to me like she's undergoing chemotherapy
or some kind of medical treatment nobody
offered her a seat nobody and she looked
quite shaky and I was so upset to see
somebody who's not just in heels and is
a middle-aged woman but someone who's
unwell obviously unwell not being given
a SE and I think that's the thing about
chivalry um although we think of it as a
courtesy that men extend to women I
think it's more than that I think that
there's a general courtesy and tolerance
and kindness which has been it's been
killed off over the years yes I I think
this is a important point because we
often think of chivalry in the context
of a relationship a romantic
relationship how people treat one
another but it's certainly doesn't have
to be in that context really at its
fundamental chivalry is good manners
which it seems from your two experiences
a lot of people are
lacking yeah I think so I mean I think
something has changed I don't quite know
when the Rocks set in but I do think
that women are partly to blame I'm not
I'm not going to say that feminism is
completely killed off chivalry but I
think that's a part of it you see
chivalry um I mean it's it's an old
medieval code isn't it it comes from sh
shal code where Knights word on honor
women help the poor be brave Etc and I
think a lot of feminists are felt that's
incompatible with feminism which in a
way it is because if you treat the Sexes
differently that's the literal
definition of sexism or sexual
discrimination you're treating them
differently and of course baked into to
the idea of chivalry is that men who are
the dominant sex would protect the
weaker sex of course that's how it was
then now lot's changed and I think that
women have made a mistake in thinking
that they need to respect these sorts of
courtesies that men extend to them now I
used to do it I used to do it all the
time I would say no if somebody offered
me a seat I think actually as a young
woman you get offered a seat more than
when you're older that's my experience
anyway but I would say no I don't know
if I actually Sneed at men or said
educate yourself but I bet I was giving
off that Vibe hands up um I didn't need
I didn't need a man to open a door for
me I didn't need him to carry a bag I
didn't want his seat now I'm 50 I kind
of do I appreciate it I love the fact
that that my sons are tall enough to
reach things off the high shelf or they
they carry things without me asking
because there is a respect in which the
Sexes are different we are physically
different and I think that acknowledging
that and being courteous about it is is
a good thing it shouldn't be seen as an
insult I think that that particular
brand of feminism that I used
to to have to exude when I was younger
came from a lack of
experience and I think that feminism
malfunctioned as it were when I had
children because there's no bigger
reminder of your difference than when
you're pregnant you give birth and you
breastfeed and you are riing basically
normally on on the man to be the
provider and to look after you for a
period of time um I think so I think
that was that was a big change for me
and I think the other thing that I've
noticed is this General lack of courtesy
which is like I say about more than a
difference between men and women it's
something that's crept into um all
aspects of public life and it's really
sad I think we do need to resurrect
chivalry um you know your article got me
thinking about my own experiences and my
conversations with my girlfriends in my
20s as opposed to my 30s and I really
resonate with what you're saying that
there was certainly a time where the
attitude was you know we're absolutely
going to split the bill he's absolutely
not opening the door because I have to
show my Independence I just think when
you become a bit more nuanced about it
all it's kind of people just
thoughtfully indicating to each other
that they care or that they value
somebody or in the in the sense of
strangers just that they're doing a nice
thing you know you get home at the end
of the day and you think gosh I I was
helpful um you know I I was a decent
person on the tube I was a decent person
on on the bus um and I I agree with you
I think that that women should bear some
of their responsibility I do Wonder
however Laura if men should bear a bit
more of their responsibility I think
it's um been very convenient perhaps for
some men uh that um the expectation has
been taken off of them um and that they
perhaps don't feel so inclined now that
they don't feel like um it's expected
your sons obviously uh being the counter
example
here and I think there are lots of them
I mean I I shared this article on
LinkedIn it was nice to share something
that was I thought a bit lighter than my
normal fair but my goodness this has got
men really angry um I think a lot of
people they've done that thing of
they've read the title and they haven't
read the article so there are lots of
men complaint on my LinkedIn that chival
is dead and it's women's fault I'm like
yes yes sir read the article um and I
think that there is a certain brand of
man like my tube o who feels quite happy
and entitled to sit on the seat I think
he's glad the expectation gone I don't
think it ever suited him in the first
place he loves planting his backside on
the mock ET seats rather than a noble
Steed he's very happy to have a beer can
and not a sword in his hand he looked
pretty comfortable and he had no shame
at all about telling me I couldn't have
a seat he had no idea what my need might
be or whether I was Ill nothing yeah so
there is a certain kind of person who is
taking this and running with it but then
if I'm going to put some criticism onto
men it's that they need to toughen up a
little bit now I talked to one chap I
know about this story and he said well
yeah I used to off of my seat and I
don't anymore because women kept turning
me down and you know if they've come
across a few women who were like Laura
when she was 18 19 20 they may be
thinking well you know screw you I
offered you a seat and I'm not doing it
again you can stand
but the thing about courtesy and
kindnesses you shouldn't be knocked back
so easily just keep going that's that's
the way to resurrect it people can
ReDiscover their own manners um
otherwise what you get is a you know we
want a circle of love we don't want to
be passing on negativity the whole time
you know you talked about coming home
and you feel I helped somebody there's
no greater feeling is there but you have
to pay it forward you have to keep
spreading it around yeah yeah and not
everybody's going to ask certainly
actually most people aren't going to ask
and you have to be prepared to have your
kindness rejected but it's a risk that I
think you know ideally you you want to
take um Laura I suppose my my last
question to you if I may is is you say
your sons are are growing up to to learn
about chivalry do you think there's
going to be a reverse here do you think
perhaps
um women realizing that they have a role
to play in this are now correcting and
they're going to be raising their sons
to be the next chivalrous generation
perhaps there's something to look
forward
to I don't know I think there's all
kinds of Corrections that are going on
actually so thinking not just about my
sons but all the teenage boys I'm
exposed to through
them while I'd say they've got their
manners about them I think a lot of
young men are actually they're kind of
swinging the other way they're they're
frightened of what happens between men
and women will a woman pin a complaint
upon them will she say that they looked
at her the wrong way I mean you got to
remember on the tube there have been
posters up as well saying that staring
is an unwanted intrusion I mean it's
gone quite far it's quite hard for young
men now to know how they should behave
because they're told that even looking
at a woman is wrong and you know I heard
uh one young man say not not my son's
but others that he he would be scared of
making a move on a woman unless she's
written down first that he can so I
think that um there are all kinds of
swings and Corrections going on and it's
not all good otherwise you wouldn't see
the rise of a phenomenon as well like
Andrew Tate who's pushing a really kind
of hyper masculine brodo version of
masculinity I don't think there've been
enough good male role models to be
honest high-profile Mass masculine ra
role models for young men and that's
that's the role of men to take up that
role actually I think that's um that's a
very good point because you know
especially when it comes to role models
celebrities and the rest of it I mean I
am still in shock and awe when I
discover that a celebrity couple has
been together for 25 years that
shouldn't be surprising but um this idea
that to be strong to be masculine to be
chivalrous um is to show respect to
women and to treat women well and you're
right unfortunately those Role Models do
feel like they've been been dwindling
and I guess we we just really need to go
back to basics
here we do chivalry the shival code
Laura thanks so much for joining
spectator
[Music]
TV